good job we are live welcome to the iron
Lords podcast episode number 63 it's
another glorious Sunday and we are back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day and
today the round will rejoice we have the
debut of the e3 2018 prediction series
and Nintendo is first up to bat I'm
extremely proud to have all this
Nintendo royalty here at the round table
so let's get right into it I want to
introduce the Lord whose journey as a
content creator has truly been one of
the most positive and meteoric Rises in
our entire gaming community whether it
be his daily news wave detailed tech
breakdowns or informative gaming
analysis all done with tremendous
production values introducing the host
of the small cast podcast and one of the
most highly requested guests to be at
the roundtable fellow switch fan 749
affair and the lord of hardware
soldering himself big debut into the
realm of the Lords mommy-o it spawned
wave media how are you doing sir good
that was an awesome intro you the
pleasure to have you a huge huge fan
you're a lord at what you do so it's
only right that we show you a proper
respect at that roundtable man
you ready today are you wrongfully oh
yeah I'm ready thank you thank you very
very humbled that you came up and of
course we have another one of my
favorites in the realm this young lord
is the originator of the movement and
along with Lord J main help coin and
popularize one of the most popping
Nintendo terminologies ever to switch
gang creators in the game amazing
developer interviews and always has his
finger on the pulse of the culture
introducing the creator and host of the
press star podcast live from the six and
making his return to the realm of the
look alive look alive
Buffy look fresh coffee
how you doing sinner yeah it's good to
be here it's about to be back
I'm shout out to the iron Lords podcast
on the spawn wave yeah man I'm ready to
talk these topics manat intro man I
can't top that real quick or go to the
residential as the originator of the of
the switch gang are we still allowed to
coerce which gang are we retiring it
what's the new movement it's been a
little bit quiet out here
we just enjoy our games right now so we
shut up to the crew fresh table podcast
Jay main Alex
Eric and all crew no doubt and of course
we have a lord who is no stranger to the
round table and who potentially is one
of the greatest allies to the realm
whether it be his thought-provoking vs
series hilarious V logs in some of the
most unique holiday videos you will ever
see on you then Florida wanted a
introducing the creator and host of the
potentially perfect YouTube channel the
Lord of the Chatterbox
and one of the illest youtubers you'll
ever see grace to guitar begging his
return to the realm of the Lords my man
Lord Aleppo are you doing sir
I'm well thank you very very ready
alright and of course we got our boy
Lord Lytton though he might be joining
us in in progress so don't don't don't
sleep he by becoming things going on but
of course we got the Four Horsemen of
game those usual suspects at the round
table
my co-host with the Como's my brother
from another mother the difficult game
conqueror and the how of the young wolf
my man Lord addict are you doing sir
pretty good wondering when that intro is
gonna get longer it's usually about
every 5 or 5 or 10 episodes you put
something else in that
Lord adequate their energy today I'm
loving it this was so yesterday I was
playing steady decay and I was getting
so like looking for legitly getting sick
from the motion blur I had to go to bed
like get to it get into it and of course
we have our most technical gaming Lord
the solo gamer who lives for the single
player selfish experience and also the
sastra Damas mr. offline profile
Illuminati himself my man Lord sovereign
are you doing sir great to know if I
feel good I feel like I got my feeling
good stuff really good and of course we
got the Incredible Hulk Ernest aka the
XS gamer the lord of combat sports was a
man of his convictions demands nothing
less than the premium experience and is
to get money game up Oh beloved Lord
King how are you doing sir we're doing
fantastic today as you know from my
tweets yesterday combats was crazy I'm
not gonna get into that today so uh and
a good friend of mine Tim dog you know
you know we chopped it up every once in
a while and he brought something to my
attention and it's been bothering me for
a while and I didn't know how to address
it now we had a a pillar in our
community that I really didn't know
personally but a lot of people did
and he was well-loved in a community um
a gaming addict I believe or addict yeah
he passed away and what what I've
noticed is that we suffer in silence as
gamers you know we have different
afflictions and stuff like that shout
out to us ah here um yes I'm here with
you in your struggle I know you put out
a video some people deal with their pain
in different ways in different forms
well but if that was like I we've said
anything I'm here for your brother that
you can reach out you can talk our
community is made up of God verse people
we are doctors we have scientists we
have nutritionists we have all types of
things we have health trains we have
everything in our community and if we
actually reach out to one another
instead of putting our hate on tweets
stuff like that and actually reach out
for help
you never know that guy that your game
with could be a nutritionist that can
actually help you balance your your diet
or you know or somebody that can help
you with whatever maybe you're that
person that can actually help somebody
so a lot of times these tweets and stuff
that we do do when we're going at each
other about games and stuff that's
really a cry for help and attention
maybe if you change it a little bit it
can actually benefit the community what
I want you to do today if you have
friends and stuff that you do talk to
you know um everybody's dealing with
something a community we are one we all
love this gaming 8-bit Nintendo Xbox
Playstation one thing is one fact and
all three of those things it's games
absolutely that's the that's the common
bond that happens again I'm so glad you
actually said that Lord King because I
can shout out the Lord's idea please you
know West Wilson in West she's been wild
as far as his recovery and everything
that's going on with him you know but at
the end of the day you know that common
thread is gangs that's what we all love
to do so we can all beef and have
console wars and have fun with all that
but it's really not in point you know at
the end of the day
people's lives are going on right now
people got things going on so thank you
Lord King you know saying for dropping
an ounce and of course it is me shallow
shinobi game himself Lord Cognito
spreading that gaming realness
IOP not telling you what you want to
hear but what you need to hear so before
we get into what the Lord's are playing
I want to actually give it back the Lord
sovereign or special nordley
announcement what's up okay so bear with
me because I'm not really good at
organizing my thoughts and not nearly as
well as Cognito so um a while back we
got some feedback from some of you guys
out there that said that you wanted to
have other ways to support the podcast
um we realize that you guys come in here
every Sunday to listen to us and support
us it's actually mind-blowing to me
because I'm content to sit here with my
boys and just talk gaming because
absolutely that's what we do right the
fact that so many of you come here
every Sunday they hear our foolishness
put a smile on your faces
to us it actually is just it just blows
us away right so um we talked about what
we would do in terms of figuring out a
way to kind of incorporate more of you
guys into the show and at the same time
do what we what we feel is the next
logical step for IOP which is improving
it on all fronts right so we came up
with a patreon and basically what it is
is it's just about us figuring out a way
to get you guys more into what ILP is
giving you guys control of certain
things with it with the funniest aspects
of the show and just basically growing
ILP um and that would not be a
possibility without you guys like the
Baptists you guys are here every single
week is is like I said mind-boggling to
us and all we want to do is to improve
that experience on all fronts so
basically we're gonna launch a patreon
and we're gonna do that today right like
then a few in a few seconds but purpose
of the patreon is it's kind of twofold
right what we want to do was like I said
find ways to get you guys engaged in the
show in funny ways and
upon the showing that and the second
part about that of that whole thing is
to improve the quality and the breadth
of what we provide so as you guys have
seen with our with our pax coverage with
our upcoming III coverage we're trying
to be everywhere right and to that end
what we want to do is to be able to
improve like our our the old video
quality right and things like that mom
and you know hopefully get some some
music intros and stuff like that I may
talk to my man to laugh about that yeah
and in the long term just hopefully be
able to give you guys even more content
because again none of this would be
possible without you guys angling the
fact that you guys support every single
week so we're gonna launch in a couple
of seconds guys like any and all sort of
suggestions criticisms bring them this
way man like all cuz we're new at this
we don't know you know we did what we
thought would be cool and funny at the
same time we focused you'll see on some
of those tears we focused on again just
thank you from the bottom of our hearts
for just being here whether you support
on patreon you don't whatever we're just
glad you're here and you're willing to
listen to us you know I just want to
improve that experience across the board
think so myself
appreciate it man yeah he said it all I
mean he links in description it's up on
Twitter and stuff like that what you're
trying to improve
thing get better like I said it's just
an extension of our Saturdays from
actually just playing games together and
having fun no doubt so we gonna get into
the what the Lords of playing let's
actually start with our guest Lord spawn
wave on what have you been actually
playing this week gauging okay I played
a I actually started playing the onrush
beta on the ps4 nice I like that that's
pretty fun there's a couple games we're
reviewing that I think you're under
embargo now so I'll leave those out but
that picked up Hyrule warriors
definitive edition yes oh nice I I tried
it on the way you I just couldn't get
into it honestly a lot of games on the
Wii U I couldn't get into so I figure
I'll take I'll give it another shot I
think this has like all the DLC and
stuffs like I'll give another shot so
clean that out too cool selection nice
diverse selection of games real cool
lore coffee what have you been playing
this week besides BG and everything yeah
I finally retire in the certain games
you know Marvel versus trash you know we
really enjoyed that half way in chapter
4 right now I'm gonna try and finish it
this long weekend if I can I'm gonna try
binge it on tropical freeze I also
picked up Hyrule warriors but I don't
down I'm gonna open it you know I think
I just bought it for collection purposes
though oh you become fighter 5 and
that's pretty much it
and of course de la Poe whatever even
get a chance to play this week man well
I was finally able to get like a
dedicated tower piece because he's have
an all-in-one r.i.p that so
now I'm actually able to play PC games
I'm able to play games and you know
recently like it's just so amazing I
don't know I don't know that I can go
back guys like getting it all together
but once you get it all together I'm
telling you it's there's nothing like it
and so I've been I've been going by
there's this Kickstarter game of wizard
of legend that was really cool and it
was like a little 8-bit or 16-bit thing
but that was really cool and then just
I've been I've been trying pub G as
someone who started off in fortnight I
do it I'm just like oh they're shooting
me where's my building game going on
right below an attic what's been going
on with you man uh I've been playing
Final Fantasy seven uh
realizing how much squirting she's gonna
mess this game up I've been playing
steady decay to everybody and then I go
I'm gonna take a minute to uh to take a
moment of silence to realize that uh Ino
March 3 wasn't an actual dream it was
actually it was well because now it's
looking like this game isn't an April
Fool's joke it's that easy starting to
thinking now is exactly think it's
coming out this year like low-key
sovereign what'd he get a chance to play
this week only my place my second
PlayStation platinum next to the order
1886 that was that I played some more
Donkey Kong Country tropical freeze that
game is fantastic
every single stage is different my gate
in the
I had to pick up an N Lord cargo know
about this Cognito knows like if there
were two did we did after school when we
were in like elementary and junior high
school we'd either go play double dragon
to the Wiz nobody good good memories
unlike the reflection
[Laughter]
I was so rude to my little Sola try hogs
on my squad and these news is already
like 367 light and storm like you you
got to really cut it out I want to see
what it's all about I'm gonna test all I
get are the guns and stuff like that is
Jeeves level these dudes is really out
there trying to burn through the DLC in
like five minutes look crazy I'm playing
that you know playing pub G being yanked
in every direction playing my god a war
really good game I'm still trying to
push my way through it
and I fired up state of decay to shout
out to the devastated and got the whole
big package of us I was playing early
before everybody else um my little quips
about the game is going in and out of
doors is a little wonky and like I was
like the motion blur I have to play that
game in like segments because I
literally start to get sick like wow
yeah and I'm not the kind of person to
like I need the affection only time I've
ever said the motion blur is a problem
yeah it's weird I mean I can't believe
we got the mention I've been playing a
lot of that too and technical aspects of
the game like the game proper like all
the systems and how they added stuff to
it like that game is all about crisis
management and having no chill like
anytime you think you got your community
right
five-minute in that regard he just
should run smooth that's all like yeah
kofi man I heard your grown man
what was that state that what was that a
state of decay grow I think you return 1
& 2 just around the same amount of time
yeah that's one game I did forget to
mention Donald's play and I didn't put
it on in 8 hours a state of decay to you
know give it a fair shot he putted two
hours later decay - and you spent the
other six complaining did you bring the
blanket to the stream that's four see if
that your he brings that blanket out oh
I was a pretty classic gift I can see a
lot of attention game what it's not even
like the bugs that actually bugged me
because like a one EOS said I didn't run
into the problem with doors you know it
was really glitchy there he's actually a
couple doors that you have to go around
like I literally had a G I was trying to
go into a gate once after about two
seconds like I'm not about this life and
just climb the wall beside it like yeah
I also was playing and I climbed
something and my personal push you get
to levitate in the air you know you know
when a game is kinda it's kind of messed
up when it has a dedicated button for
when you get stuck you know I mean like
if you get chops I use that also plug
there's nothing like completely game
breaking cuz me on the PC on the PCs
actually runs pretty good you know like
era is pretty good up my frame rates are
high but it's it's just the gameplay
it's not for me to grind the grind is a
little too much like got you absolutely
crazy in it and it just got repetitive
after like eight hours
did you play the first one at all you
doesn't really give it I gave it a
chance because I know a lot of people
been telling me about it I also heard
these problems prior say not you know
it's the first ones very buggy this that
dances so when I heard about Sadie -
Kate - I want it just to you know play
the first one a little bit I was
matching it's a beat it or anything - I
just wanted to get a feel of it what
getting into the problem with you chose
to play it like you got around to
playing it and a time where like you
shouldn't be playing that game it was
the craziest part I was about to say
that he's able to jump and come back be
real quick yeah I'm sorry finished up
coffee they'll jump yeah yeah but
overall like what really bothered me
about the game was it's just the
repetitive repetitiveness of the game
you know the Granite's alone too much
and the combat the game is okay like
look every game pretty much has you
doing like the same thing over and over
if you really think about it right if
what is what you're doing fun you know
that's the question you gotta ask they
gotta make games like this really solid
when it comes to the gameplay department
like the gunplay and stuff like that and
I thought this was just it was just it
wasn't like terrible was just okay so
like I've been hours I thought I was
done on my head of Microsoft ask for
that refund and they gave it to me god
bless Microsoft and your customer
support cuz their your honesty
spectacular I think they need to be
commended man I always pull up to them
ask for refunds they're so kind like you
know how people tell you to actually
like do surveys and all that [ __ ] for
Mac stop I'm actually pull up and do a
survey for them and give them five stars
because you're actually amazing and you
know deals with me me the promotion I'm
really happy I paid I paid $67 stated
cash I got it all back pay eight hours
of it I know maybe when it cuz I'll see
I might give it a go if it does I think
but pretty much I think I'm done I think
I'm done it's not so I mean to give the
gameplay doesn't doesn't suit you it's
not gonna ever change like that yeah I
agree you have jumper real quickly they
were finished after when we playing on
yeah same thing state of decay shout out
to what
dealer gaming Co Eastwood more sinister
got a chance to test out the coop the
actually surprise tethering wasn't that
bad so I'm actually I'm fun with it we
did encounter
some some walk and some genk they pulled
up an advantage outside and it was look
like a pile of scrap parts on my screen
but but at least the tethering was an
issue so we still don't mess that up
as far as the switch I actually picked
up my first banner soccer game so I
picked up banner saga force which I'm
enjoying and actually I've never played
one before kind of RTS I think a Attic
you'd like it the only thing that differ
from XCOM is that instead of the normal
turn base it's like grid-based
no it's kind of like you don't XCOM all
your units move and then the enemy with
banners it's you move one unit they move
the next unit like back and forth so
it's a unique kind of take on RTS but I
like it the cinematics are pretty cool
trying to just get into the story and
stuff that and shout out to abnormal
games they hit me with a review copy for
stay and that's I'm actually in San
indie title on the Xbox right now I'll
show on Steam really cool it's kind of
like this dude who kind of like I guess
he was a therapist or something he kind
of helped somebody broke into his house
knocked him over the head kidnapped him
and left him in a room with a computer
so basically you're his only person that
you can actually communicate with so
it's kind of like a psychological girl
he's trying to earn your trust
you trying to help him get out in the
unique mechanic of the game where it's
called stay is anytime that you don't
play the game the game actually tracks
that and that affects his mood in all
his emotional states so check it out
when you get a chance to stay on
abnormal games pretty cool but not for
that what the lords are playing stuff
let's get to the reason why we are here
series the tendo's in the building we've
got the switch gang family meeting we
got all powerful Nintendo here so we
gonna start talking about what's going
on so basically started off with the
stage I just want to point out something
coffee try to tell me in a Nintendo dude
I don't know how why do you guys claim
that dough like I'm actually curious
like we have to get to the bottom of
this songs you've coined switch King
okay I didn't make that phrase though
that
that's a fast beat money I know that
actually was rapping that flag or Jamie
all yeah because no one and that was
announced everybody was on the fence if
the portability was a gimmick and y'all
like we were the only ones like yo this
is a goal and I feel like it's only
comment look for me look before the
whole switch thing came out there was
rumors of it being like a portable
console as soon as I heard portable
already knew this [ __ ] was gonna take
off you don't have 20 bets with people I
had an EEG on he's gonna be throwing out
the ps4 out the window real soon you
know he's gonna finish that portable
consoles you know assaults as soon as I
heard that like this platform was gonna
be on the global type platform already
knew it was gonna be is gonna take off
you know um so Sarah's denied the whole
switch gang how it started yeah after
watching to reveal that I might get
worse which guy was when people said ask
you that switch gagged and Erica K but
oh my why you know be funny if I did
like a little bit of a parody song
that's right an old switch guy shoutout
to fame - he was talking about flags I
just compiled all these jokes until one
thing maybe made a stupid little parody
song before it took off from there then
it got even worse when I put Omega and H
are you collecting all the games to the
other platforms you have or is that just
a switch um I'm over I think I almost
have 300 games on Steam um you guys
already know I play a lot of games on
PlayStation even Xbox I pretty much buy
every single Xbox but you refer to them
for like you are the originator yeah
I've only responded let's get it right
David addict only refunded to Xbox games
ever and I bought one back for
that that's not that's not home
I bought that back and I refund it's
state of decay either do that I bought
record beat it
I beat woo - Vince I beat Forza horizon
3 I got a lot hours in that and my
driver level I beat I didn't beat Forza
Motorsport 5 but I have a [ __ ] ton hours
in that you know I mean like I play all
these games what I do man no down real
quick real quick before you jump off in
the first stop we got royalties in the
building is that law up there was one of
the up-and-comers in the games dedicated
to the brands evident everything he does
from his a balanced opinion pieces nin d
showcase series and his competitive
late-night streams there's too many do
saeng's right now ada in hopes of the
Nintendo Direct Channel the designer
behind some of the best thumbnails on
YouTube and the only Lord to ever get
his kids for Nintendo lab or camera
welcome to the realm of the Lord's Bobby
Lord Nintendo Direct are you doing man
I'm doing good I'm doing good man man I
was fighting that church traffic man
thank you for making it man I appreciate
it man so we gonna get into it man we
would talk a lot of rain blur long
enough but up yeah so basically what's
been going on Nintendo obviously it's
it's the state of Nintendo 2018 they've
had a new president you know it's kind
of from that younger Famicom days new
blood and obviously we got the online
infrastructure announcement and pricing
and stuff like that we also hear about
Virtual Console being dead and a whole
bunch of leaks in a fresh shut up King
like how do we feel about the switch
momentum coming into e3 well I mean they
started the year off Oh
okay but it's a it's been a lot of like
Wii U ports and that's that's fine for
people who don't have it or didn't have
a Wii U or people just weren't a fan of
the way you like me but for everyone
else it seems like it's been kind of a
slow start to the year for the system
but man building up to e3 and mostly
because of Pokemon that's all everyone
let's talk about it is like what is
intended gonna do there I mean if you
look at YouTube it's like 80 million
videos of Pokemon rumors Pokemon rumors
and and people are talking about that
and Smash so they seem to have good
momentum going in III just because Sony
already told us pretty much everything
they're gonna show us it's a lot of
stuff and Microsoft has struggled to get
I guess a critically acclaimed game
going in the last I mean how long has it
been G tell us game Forza horizon 3 yeah
I mean I still home like how calls you
remember that like God of War took over
for the longest time I played God of War
for so long now and I was ready for
stated K to come out and be like insane
ridiculous and it it kind of it kind of
fell off a bit there when it came out
and people saw them people judge
Metacritic scores like it's you know oh
yeah and all but the fact that I talked
to a couple people before reviews one
out and they told me that in a game with
perma death their characters are falling
through the level that's a little
worrying right there I was like you know
what I'll game pass it that's fine
Tuesday that's fine
but I mean they're people I guess who
went out like Kofi you bought it for
bucks or something fifty bucks so you
know you get that and it's feels like an
early access game but I mean Nintendo
has at least used games from last
generation where I mean the way you did
not I mean how well do we use sell
thirteen and a half million and it's
four years out and at this point it's
pretty clear the switch has an audience
that's at least fifty or sixty percent
of people who didn't have a Wii U at all
so I mean you look at the sales and I'll
tell you that tropical freeze outsold
the Wii U version in two weeks in Japan
yeah and I have a feeling it'll be at
least
in the top maybe the top five and MPD's
so I mean that's really telling you own
teeth no there but I do think we need to
see some more stuff from them in terms
of first party but they definitely some
third party stuff but their momentum is
is at least good going into e3 good
enough probably out of the three
probably the best at this point the
point let's go in here man how do you
feel I'm not watching him because I'm
telling I've got some I think Nintendo
whenever we okay we always know that
they they always with the projections
they always go under because they know
they know exactly what they're gonna hit
the switch it's it's been no exception
with that all I know is that going into
this there's gonna be something it's
gonna be there's gonna be something
people it's all about the discussion
when it comes to e3 what people are
talking about after before they've
already got people's ears right now
before e3 I'm telling you there's gonna
be something crazy I'm telling you you
feel something for some big dick in
there but yeah let's keep it all buck
like like this you know the ten dozen
out the baddest e3 is set up for
Nintendo for victory like I tweeted
about this like Nintendo got the most
surprises that's just a fact they got
the mono come out they're gonna show
deaf strand and obviously it's gonna
look fantastic you're Phil you right now
and if you two left me in here alone
he just doesn't like mention them
mentioned in the same breath as as Xbox
[Laughter]
was a real assistance but I'm projecting
looking like this gonna lap the Xbox
this year so take a look at the media
creates after Pokemon launches yeah so
like just looking at e3 this year let's
keep an eye on it what Microsoft they
won't be popping until like 2021
you're gonna come back we're gonna see
Forza horizon expected I'm pretty sure
it's gonna blow our minds um it's gonna
be I mean a rumor is gonna be in Hong
Kong or Tokyo or something like that I'm
all for that so that's that's fantastic
news for me for me um guess what we're
gonna seriously crackdown 3 that games
mark stuff but I'll talk about the
details you know I'm coming I'm coming
tight we're about three good that looks
spooky you know I mean you know I mean
it's gonna look spooky so I'm just I'm
just trying to say like Microsoft we're
gonna see probably dear great games
because we see them acquiring studios
and stuff like that later down the line
you know so this III I'm my my
expectations for Microsoft is actually
really low I think I'm gonna have very
few surprises they will a surprise about
very few in my personal opinion I'm Sony
berry came out and that's what they're
announcing but Nintendo I'll be back on
attend oh I see what you gonna mean they
already announced a fire emblems coming
out
here 2018 they haven't shown anything of
it that's gonna be this year at e3 we
have a Yoshi game that we barely seen
anything else look at these people
acting like they have fresco look III
Loki could be thirty minutes all these
executives come onstage talking all this
nonsense till what we really care about
then today we wanna say so we got dad we
already know smash come in the heavily
rumored Pokemon games come in we hear
some of them all starfox so I feel like
Nintendo's now that we gonna memorize
are we gonna we're gonna mention the
rumour name for the Pokemon next topic
don't know just yet but basically you
feel that the momentum is just so neat
Sony's gonna do you feel that low-key a
lot of people gonna be disappointed from
Microsoft based on what we've heard what
we know so far is that what you going
yeah pretty much yeah no doubt let me
get out Lord Nick Tendo you just jumped
in well the stage is set for Nintendo at
this point honestly yes go
actually actually switch down here I was
gonna bring all my meatballs I got a
whole new ball squatting that's amiibo
squad he's got a whole squad let me let
me explain a couple of things the fact
that your meatball game is lowly [ __ ]
that means that you're really hanging on
by a thread from last year with all the
line we do games so now that you're
sliding into 2018 with all the old games
oh hey there's new it's new again we
shining up turns oh what was told
masterful adventures is coming back
where do you primarily PLIM I'm guessing
next box though right services straight
trash right before even else that I said
is gonna be straight trash because like
[Applause]
Nintendo we were very hopeful I did with
me a salty check out what we talked
about how I was not I was not for it I'm
glad that you know because I know what's
gonna be garbage so the fact that is
official garbage now is official
official garbage here's how they going
next to you here it is alright we spun
their garbage now let's get them all for
the next trash all right so I heard all
y'all talk about um you know we got to
sell the Hyrule warriors there was
already out on something else if Xbox
and with no advancements in graphics on
your Twitter page am I gonna see any
retweets from leg herb talking about
backwards compatible games because games
this year
basically what you because of the the
fact that the Wii U games are being
brought back out but at a premium when
it came out for the Wii U it was like
thirty nine fifty straight garbage
alright alright these are the games that
y'all gonna be looking forward to all
y'all talk about is hope that got Jesse
Jackson one of your promos we can't
dispute the
- sales success titles being put out so
like a game like a Mario Cart and stuff
that all these games that can marry
yeah remastered ano showing tremendous
success even like exploring before we
was saying about you know was it the
donkey kong country of free you got a
bunch of people are coffee buying an
opening crime alright so don't sit here
and try to back off your crime you know
why you can't return we're getting a lot
of returns out here you got on the state
of Nintendo but you know all that junk
aside all that my fan boy ISM with
Microsoft aside um what I'm looking
forward to is I really want a real
pokemon game like or Pokemon go type of
game where my switch that can actually
take my switch outside and go also I'm
looking forward to what they gonna talk
about where I'm a real metroid fan I
brought my switch for original titles
alright so when you hear me talk about
the fact that I'm not liking the games
that came out before and they keep on
reskin in these games talking about here
here's all the deals seeing his these
games it's not making me excited
fighting for you bright you you were a
guy let's just give the context right
for small aiming everyone like King was
a Wii U supporter like he went saw so at
the end of the day I can understand his
perspective
me um say I didn't buy the wheel so all
these titles are new titles to me so I
understand this is not exciting even
though they haven't you're waiting for
the check this out at this point
how long is um III I hear the jokes II
know the ports and I I agree definitely
got it we you a lot of these games are
repeats for you I'm saying but how long
is this gonna last like for at least
four more games than get it while you
can for more good games is done they're
gonna retort them and then they're gonna
start port in gang Cuban game King and
in the fact that they're put in shop and
basically making us pay for them cut in
a remaster yeah so that's my Twitter
I've been very vocal about how I think
yes online is very trash I'm creature on
gaming addict attest to this you
probably have seen me say this a million
times the way that they're implementing
voice chat I'm not going out
something like that he does good
pretending you can pretend I've been
honest I can't send a message and I do
waited a whole year for that this is
absolutely terrible there's one there's
one saving grace there's one saving
grace and this is what Microsoft needs
to learn is game you don't think it's
great game week I'm seen I'm not gonna
say no nice guy shut up
Carlo name though I get some problems I
see all these Xbox man's retweeting
Larry herb about these old-ass games
nice games I mean I just bought burnout
for 10 bucks is pretty good cannot be
Xbox I bought the switch and I got what
I wanted from this switch was owed
anything after that is just a bar
opponents like you know I pretty much
like people have to force me to play
this switch I mean I didn't by order
today it shouldn't be forced to play
anything you know like I will play the
new Super Smash Brothers I will play the
Pokemon game but like at the end of the
day and you know I mess to some Mario
games I didn't live Odyssey didn't
really give me that bill I thought it
would cuz I was a big fan of Mario 64
but for some reason I just was not
messing with that game okay
I beat Zelda before most people in this
pattern like three days oh here we go so
I'll be so pretty much that's what your
your whole thing addict is Zelda I
remember for
switch was announced and zelda was
announced at I really hit an emotional
because I people when they delayed
remember when the rumors currents gonna
get delayed I said I'm not buying the
slave you will let you told me some
message that would be a mistake now with
that with a half you told me your exact
words with they have to have Zelda on
launch and you did call that as far as
the success of going on I want to let
law solve regard this first off like
when it comes to the Xbox thing like we
don't know what anyone's announcing well
yeah I've been told to expect expect
bare minimum that make this the Xbox has
been argued in the in the podcast like
at the end of the day no one else no
makes a king
there's a lot of hope for Microsoft fans
going or Xbox fans Microsoft 3 honestly
I'm absolutely terrified to see it doing
exactly what we said they were going to
do nobody out here believed that they
were going to have the start to this
unit they had to last you don't have
Mara in the pipeline you have you have
to big up these other titles that are
coming down the pipeline and they made
it clear the biggest ones are not come
until after e3 end of the year so we're
not saying smashes into the end of the
year so they're right where I expected
them to be in terms of like I grew a
coffee when it comes to like biggest
surprises at e3 I think they're poised
to do that because you got to remember
like let's look at the Walmart League
right most of the league stuff is mostly
PlayStation stuff and Xbox stuff
anything I'm
engine for Nintendo with stuff that we
knew is in the pipeline already they've
always been the best at creepy keeping
stuff close to the vest fact you know
who knows what we'll see in the next
couple of weeks I got a question how do
we know they haven't pulled a stunt me
already and they've already announced
which with on smash and if Pokemon is
even playable doesn't have the launch to
see if it's playable at e3 it's a wrap
alright so obviously we know that uh
there's been two leaders this heavy room
is right now about two Pokemon let's go
titles like Evie and Pikachu if it's
like Pokemon go I'll pass
well that's what the rumors are you know
remakes up and heavily integrated with
the current Pokemon go which meant you
know not be a r1 but so again the rumor
is that at the end of May we're getting
close to enemy so I want to get lost for
a wave actually in a potential perfect
innit as far as like what do we feel
about one these rumors and the impact
that these titles go so let's start with
lost ball what do you what do you feel
about these Pokemon girl rumors for
integration with Pokemon go I'm not
really sure how they're gonna do it
outside of throwing the pokeball because
the switch doesn't have GPS doesn't have
a camera I have no idea what kind of
integration they would have outside of
the throwing mechanic for the pokeball
like you're not going to go outside with
your switch
but you're not I mean your I could doing
that stuff on the switch I feel like the
integration might be some of the
mechanics with that maybe they can share
special events that they do throughout
the year maybe if you sign into one and
then the other you get something no
that's that's all I could really think
of between them really and if they are
going back to if they're doing remakes
of yellow and everything like people are
talking it's it's for old people like me
and some of us here on the fly know like
took over for have like what a month
where people were in the street with
their phones and stuff and you know they
made an obscene amount of money so they
they probably looked at that and said
you know we'll do that with the switch
we'll sell probably six million switches
in a month just and then they're gonna
they're gonna pretty much take over
probably November with that if it comes
out just because it's for all people
like us you know I have a question cuz
I've kept up completely with this
Pokemon go Fiasco is the moment I was
told it was let's go is it not the
standard Pokemon game listen listen
listen let this what I'm gonna give you
guys my predicts is real quick um look
they already came out and said it's
gonna be a tradition RPG they already
came that yes that's recorded that's
documented yes they said it's gonna be a
traditional core Pokemon RPG the whole
people are freaking out because they
said caching there's a little line in
the leases or the rumor catch and
Pokemon will be like catch a Pokemon
will be like in go you know I mean so
that got people absolutely freaking on
it and it does sound spooky but like
like spawn wave says the switch doesn't
have a camera no it does not GPS it's
not gonna do none of that
AR stuff Gration is if you have played a
Pokemon game before after you weaken a
Pokemon after a battle or whatever you
lied and you put them to sleep or
whatever I think I think I think when
you get them when you're actually
throwing the Pokemon instead of just
selecting there they're probably gonna
do like some sort of stupid like mini
game or like that you know just like a
Pokemon go that's how I feel like the
integration is gonna be like so I think
um some people are freaking out for no
reason it's rumored to be take place and
cancel remake of yellow so it seems
pretty interesting we will see how it
turned out No
the prominent chat he's saying that a
year back myself MPD said that Pokemon
could draw multiple multiple in home
purchases so do we feel that impact is
from from buying standpoint of people
getting multiple switches in the same
home you know will that will Pokemon
have that kind of impact when I bring it
back to spawn wait for a second even he
was jumping in on this product do you
think they would have that kind of
impact yeah yeah when I when I was I
used to work at several retail stores
and I would sell one family for 3ds or
for two DSS and I would sell I'm not
kidding eight copies of Pokemon Wow drop
they would seriously drop like six $700
to present right like I'm c'mon so this
is this is gonna be subdued do you ever
do ever pay attention any of the Pokemon
sales like prior to this like with it's
ridiculous or not like 15 million by
like February for both like together out
so gears award the Pokemon fan base is
like the most reliable fan I mean Iman
is it's alright let's let's be realistic
here
it's the same game consistently because
most times over and over again but they
continue to buy it because they're such
big fans of the series they'll buy new
systems or Pokemon so when it does come
out on the switch you're gonna see the
influx of 3ds I mean to be fair it might
be the same game over and over again but
it's always different in a lot of
different ways like the colossal tower
and silver I mean they always put stop
me remembering in a joto silver and gold
they were literally just going to have
Johto as a region in the lead designer
he said he had to argue with them for
like ever and they finally let him put a
candle in the game why they're always
doing stuff to drastically change the
game but it's got the same gameplay
mechanic yeah it has the same like
battle system and everything like they
mentioned that it might change the
battle system and people lost their mind
yeah I don't I don't think I'll be
messing with did they change the battle
says hey yeah a lot of people be upset
day gimpy or
make it even more simpler than the
standard like if it's a standard Pokemon
game to where you know I do the gems I
have that online multiplayer that I want
I'm cool with that
but if it's anything like Pokemon my god
shut up game the one thing I've heard
about this new Pokemon game is they're
actually gonna use the online absolutely
well compared to the old 3ds in terms of
the app no no not I don't mean you got a
voice chat it's they're gonna probably
do some some things with online I was
thinking events or who knows I mean
people were thinking it was gonna be a
full-on like MMO or something but oh I
do have the for people who are curious I
just see some people the chat the sales
numbers from Nintendo's Japan I our site
for their investors Pokemon X&Y sixteen
point two million you know Pokemon Sun
and Moon in the funny part about ball
games take a fraction of the cost to
make to make beer it doesn't the new
president also have some type of
connection to Pokemon is way let's get
let's get a little apple with here me
what do you feel about the impact
Pokemon also with these rumored titles
announced the Pokemon let's go
Eevee oh c'mon let's go Pikachu I'm a
huge I'm a new Pokemon person like in my
desk right now it's like mountains of
Pokemon cards later I go in on Pokemon
and I'm gonna tell you right now it does
not matter what they call these games I
mean so as far as that goes Mars
nomenclature people getting upset about
that so we shouldn't be worried about
the names alright as far as the quality
of the games no I think for the
development time though he I think
people need to scale back their
expectations what this game is going to
be what it's going to look like that you
think is just gonna be like a read like
a CD
engine I think that's what it's gonna be
yes spent so long making these models
for these pokemons I don't think that
you're like you're doing that all over
it and I think they're just gonna HD
everything like the 3ds version honestly
I just want the game to look like the
newer ones like I don't even have to
look at by.ya finish upload a lot
problems up yeah but I think that I
think the beautiful thing about what
this new title could bring is that it
really does and I know a lot of people
get upset when you say this but it
appeals to a lot of people and the idea
that like the leaks do I mean so number
one if you say it's going back to Kanto
you are yeah sign me up a new word poke
the Pokemon fans with you know the the
elements of Pokemon Sun and goes would
you like to ride a Pokemon if you if
you're not part of the Pokemon you know
fanbase you really won't realize like
how important those were and how big a
deal those actually where this is new
for me
mm-hmm because of things like HMS and
that kind of thing so it's it really
does have a broad appeal and the fact
that it's pom Evie and Pikachu in the
week
people love Eevee people people go crazy
for the we have out we're gonna have
some iron Lords face each other and you
got never played a poker game this will
literally be my first experience the
last one we're talking like a hundred to
two hundred hours and every one of them
do you guys want to know do you guys
wanna know why they're having this
Pokemon go integration if you look at
the revenue the Pokemon go has made it
makes really a lot of sense from their
perspective Pokemon go in his first
three months six hundred million dollars
in revenue wow that's insane
Lord Nintendo man what do you feel
Pokemon let's go um look I'm gonna Isis
been the first poke this would be the
first Pokemon that I played in a long
time and I think the last one I played
was on the Game Boy Advance I can't
remember which one it was so it's been a
long long time since I played so like
like he said the rumors that they're
going back to cancer like that really
hit home with me so that's what really
has me jumping on I'm just like may I
get to go back back
used to be when I was a kid and so I
mean as far as the whole Pokemon go
integration like I'll agree Kofi I don't
think it's going to be anything too
crazy other than they're just going to
utilize the motion controls to throw the
pokeballs or things like that
I don't think is gonna be anything too
crazy as far as the title i'm preciate
it just banking off the success of
pokemon go like if you hear let's go
when you hear pokemon you hear pokemon
go it's a sensation so they're just
banking off that that's that's what I
think about Elias Lee but yeah I'm not
too worried about it the game's gonna do
well and I'm pretty sure if it goes back
to Kanto I'll be in I'm all them already
outlaw Sovereign Lord King over
breakfast it'll be my first experience
to like I was a little too old to really
get into the Pokemon by the time are you
guys excited about this damn game with
your ass does not understand so white so
you mad that I want to play it now
pokemons come to you a played Pokemon
with the first time like then why did
you play like the 30 installs of the
game because that's the thing though you
can't argue with me on that cuz I will
be one on all of this tell my NES SNES
the old nasty-looking 3ds
I did three years he never played
Pokemon I just don't get it I don't
wanna hide something up you've never
played it's gonna run slipshod to
everybody I'm not hyping it up I want to
play it I want to see what it is cuz
it's on the switch I'm not hyping it up
like birthday it's on the side you guys
are ridiculous and because it's on the
switch now you wanna mess yes that's why
this is the build-up to like the first
home console version of Pokemon has been
going on for 52 that's pretty much why
whole in the switch every single chance
you get and the moment we say we want to
play something that you kind of like
house disagree we have to agree to
dismiss it but seriously about the
impact of it sound like you it's a rap
it's a rap yeah game comes out this year
again that you never play gotcha it's
gonna be a rat I wanna know what let me
put this down alright so all information
that I've gathered from all of you
individuals that eloquently put it to on
a plate for me
smash it and throw it on the floor um my
son I brought my son every last one of
those pokemons and actually I played a
couple of pokemons my best Pokemon was
on the Gamecube I had so much fun with
it I'm not gonna lie
now what you explained to me was the
super shortcomings with the switch
system apart from resolution apart from
Internet apart from chat
apart from camera so you're telling me
the best ideal place to play pokemon go
if it is a Pokemon go tighter we'll be
on it three years because it has the
gyro it has the camera has the location
as everything I don't want to play a
Pokemon go game man it's not and the
reason why is the traditional RPG is
because you can't do it right on a goal
format which was my um remember
initially my ignorance to the matter of
the limitations of the system has been
shown because my stupid ass was saying
oh man I can't wait to play pokemon go
on a switch did you imagine me outside
in the street so the fact that spoke
wave just so eloquently served this up
to me and just said yo it can't do it so
you hoping and wishing for that aspect
to ever happen so I can experience it
but my thing is okay so I have to wait
for the next iteration to get exactly
what I want from it as far as playing
wait wait oh I do play pokemon games um
but I stepped away from it and I like
Pokemon tournaments like those games
like Oh tokens maybe like that that's
that's the attack that was actually fun
for me but the thing I hate when I see
announced gosh yeah that's what that's
the thing that you might use that I like
I like the actual fighting aspect of it
an actual growing of them opposed to
or is it still the first one okay um so
you know I'll get it for my son and that
will probably be a way for me to
facilitate a purchase of a switch for my
son mm-hmm you see so you're gonna get
the numbers I don't play sales figures
all right so I can't sit there and jump
on top of six million sold and play six
million sold I can't do that
so that doesn't appeal to me what
appeals to me is games so give me the
games and I will play how much in this
format of it being just the traditional
one okay that dad does for me poking to
know I'm winning man I hear I hear what
you guys say that was like the biggest
thing I would sell to is like a family
like a dad and their son would play
pokemon it's actually it was actually
pretty cool to see that because they
would all Buy and they play together so
I can see you're right you'll see
multiple switch unit cell and then this
house brick yeah he's already three kids
all of them play the switch I'm actually
one just to get from dissipate myself
acaba shoot me I mean you pretty much
like we were hear these rumors they seem
pretty legit you know as far as you know
there's actually coming out coming into
fruition hopefully we hear more by the
end of May or at the direct itself
I'll just curious it would be like I
said for a lot of people if they've
never played okay if I gave and they do
own the switch so this one's ears are
not playing oh my god looking for people
like me you don't say so I'm definitely
interested sometime you don't pick that
up and drop it all right next topic
we're gonna focus this gonna be focused
or dalabo in Nintendo so pretty much we
just heard that uh the star fox spin-off
competitive racing game has been kind of
and it's a studios so kind of rumors of
a 20-19 release open-world hub so
there's been very controversial because
obviously we know Star photographer I
want to get a waffle in the candidate
but uh yeah so pretty much you know we
know where Star Fox has always
traditionally
right this you know right spaceship
shooting that kind of thing and now
they're talking about almost like a
diddy kong racing style with online boss
battles and stuff like that so these
Twitter streets has been crazy it's very
controversial people are like why are
they doing it you know
can you change I know the lot but you
had a great video and actually you -
nothing about you know people need to
chill out about it so I want to bring it
to you - both now that we're hearing
about this and this room seems to be
true you know what's your feeling on it
I had to make a video to talk about this
first
yes you're not you're not talking I got
yet but all jokes aside let's start with
a dick tender well what do you what do
you feel man about this this whole
direction I'm gonna come into this with
an open mind when I heard the rumor and
I first thought you know a racing game
star was racing I was like that just
Star Wars Star Fox Racing it just seemed
far-fetched and then more details came
out about the combat it was gonna be
sort of like Diddy Kong Racing I started
to get a little bit more comfortable
with it
but man I mean it's gonna be an I want
it to be ambitious it's going to be
ambitious it's gonna be a change but
yeah I don't know how I feel about it I
like I said I'm just gonna try to go
into with the whole agency if it's a
Diddy Kong Racing clone and it's just
got Star Fox skins in it I don't know
about it that's my big way what do you
feel that video freaking out in the
video is a rare rare track record I mean
with with what they've done before -
Star Fox and now we're over on retro
retro who has a pedigree that I mean
it's mark it's hard to match I'm just
gonna go and say that right now I doubt
it's gonna be a bad game regardless of
what it is what it looks like I think
Lord King said something really
interesting in the fact that he like
spoken and that's not a traditional
Pokemon game at all no thanks exactly
and so what it means is that Star Fox is
it's something it's once again I just
want to draw back to the video what I
said about what expanding what a brand
means and what a franchise means
Mario isn't just the person who runs and
jumps on kuboos any
okay like all he'll play tennis he's
playing tennis and at the end of the day
he can always go back and run and jump
on Koopas and no one ever questions
anything so at the end of the day when
starfox moves over to erasing genre
whatever it ends up being he it doesn't
mean that your traditional starfox or
whatever starfox is at its core is going
away oh just me so just to be able to
market it to more people and more people
gonna be enjoy it in hell
you never know somebody's like hey I
really like the starfox grand Pete game
what is the starfox 64 game you don't
even they might go back and check it out
you never know what its opening it up
some new so pretty much you have full
confidence in red I absolutely Metroid
Prime ended up being a my favorite game
on the Gamecube and there were a lot of
good games on GameCube but that ended be
my favorite game I bought it at like
trilogy again on the Wii U I bought the
trilogy all the we actually I bought it
every time it came out if it comes out
again I'm buying it again because retro
does something magical franchises and I
am Telling You they they are gamers at
heart they love what they do they're
artists they're artists Lord addict
since you couldn't wait to get him hand
in cofee oh now sleep Wow anyone my the
only one that played the last starfox
some needed to happen maybe oh my god
you didn't like running around your room
with that big tablet like people sitting
here like you know I like blind you I've
always said blender makes great cause
it's like if you look at his last video
he made a good point like there's not
two all you replace let's be real here
an actual racing starfox and what we get
now starfox isn't too much of a stretch
like now it's not at all late and people
who say it isn't like if it's like diddy
kong racing there were bosses and diddy
kong racing that's what they said they
active rumor is that they're actually
going to be online boss battles in two
and hey the other thing people are
saying that it's probably of caught me
because i know you talked about it as
well
people are saying that what they've seen
that the graphics are rumored to be stun
like I think that that's a lot do with
the art style retro if you look at
retros games they tend to get a lot at a
very little when it comes yes I think it
has to do with our art style like like
Metroid Prime if you go back and look at
that game looks like a 360 game on the
Gamecube but it runs the sis's frames
per second Thanks
so yeah that definitely gives me
confidence in action but I'm surprised
Attica thought you would not be feeling
you don't do well with direction changes
like we got what came out you was
initially a little hesitant that other
starfox it was bad luck OFI the smaller
add-on of starfox it wasn't the main
game was the other one that people said
that they liked mmm can't like it came
with it I forgot what the heck is call
me Star Fox 64 was a great game short
game to see it in the racing genre and
have it I hope I have confidence in
retro I agree with the lovable that
retro touches everything they touch
turns to go I wanted to be a mix of
Diddy Kong and f-zero if you give me
that evidence I mean otherwise it needs
to really differentiate I suppose
otherwise my thinking is like why not
just make a couple of starfox levels in
Mario Kart or something like that right
and Mario Kart like that so it has to
really differentiate itself so if it
does that and it gives you that and it
gives you that all on me f-zero speed
and at any depth if it's anything like
Diddy Kong it's not gonna be anything
like Mario Kart yeah right and to me
that's what it needs to be for it to
really be viable again I to take it into
a different direction yeah thinking
needs it I think is kind of kind of
slumping so speeding right it just made
a duty con racing to be honest
kofi man what would you feel you nervous
are you
oh man when I first heard it I'm sorry
Fox Racing my mind went to like ill like
right away
that's my very very very my very first
reaction I click the link to read
continue reading about the rumor then I
read that yo is it's gonna be styled
like dated car race is gonna have the
adventure mode little lost fights and
anyone who played Duty car racing racing
the the dinosaur up the of the mountain
is [ __ ] you don't say that's like to
listen listening o'clock you but yeah I
know I'm talking if y'all played IndyCar
races so and then I thought about the
possibilities of what this game
potentially could beat and it kind of
click with me and I'm like you know this
might actually work you know you know
our Fox got the characters know to do it
all so they said the gameplay would be
like f-zero so it's not pretty cool too
um I also read a rumor somewhere around
that don't be like Oh be combat so maybe
while you're racing it's like it's kind
of like an action racing game like you
shoot too so that'll mean pretty awesome
I want to see it nah man I want to see
it it's trash you know
it's ugly let me jump in because I
actually what you just said actually
struck a chord with me too because at
first like you said actually raw
emotions were exactly your room or
emotions coughing and it was just like
what did they do it and then it's like
then I started you know I listen and I
know retros credit green I'm like okay
cool and then when I heard the oil on
bass battles I'm like okay alright and
then the thing that I'm hoping is see
I'm more of a I'm a wipeout kind of guy
so I'm thinking if they even have some
resemblance a tear and you know that
competitive combat unlike almost like a
wipeout style racer as well and you
don't some like online battles
definitely I want to see I want I'm
being open-minded to I want to give him
a shot but ultimately at the end of the
day the only thing I was worried at
first when I had the negative reaction
was like well they already got Mario
Kart
why would you you know try to compete in
that space you know I'm saying kind of
thing that was you in attend oh yeah
that was how I was - I was like what why
do we need a racing game you're
until I started getting details of the
rumors of the combat you know online
boss battles and that's why I became
more open-minded to it
so I'm willing to see you know the
direction change and like you said I
think what it is is one of those
Nintendo franchises that ultimately you
know you know commercially what the
others have done I'm psyched for it
because it's new I purchased the system
for new stuff so so don't we skin me
something the same old that you get I
don't want that I want new so when they
said boss battles they said we raced and
we're doing this are you taking it there
I'm taking it there - I'm purchased but
what I've hear from you guys and I like
it because it's different that's in in a
sense right um Nintendo guys have a
pedigree right we have a backing and we
can fall back like potentially said
retro is artists yeah they never did him
dirty in that game so he purchases it
any way he can get it right all the way
to so when you have that loyal fan base
that said we love your game to this
extent you got called lunch and hope
that it will work out right though you
won't get a negative reaction and I'm
only saying this to to to talk to
whatever Microsoft execs is watching
this ring when you build I know you can
look great
game and great franchises that carries
over consistency leads to longevity
longevity leads to financial wealth
right so they are consistent that's what
the flux comes from so being
inconsistent allows Microsoft to falter
like y'all say y'all I don't know what
the hell they're gonna do Nintendo told
you we might have this we might have
that but you're hopeful it's said like
you said it's set up for them to win
this game is a perfect analogy to the
fact that you guys know that the game is
coming they told you the synapses of the
game and you're hopeful that the game
will work out well you have a couple of
few that said it's going to work out
regardless because it's retro those
built that deck their wealth inside they
start so you guys can take stock in it
and I feel it I'm buying again anyway
because no doubt so King I'm actually
surprised this time everyone's pretty
much gonna be I did not I thought this
time was gonna be mad smoked emotional
can it's believed I'm sorry conceived oh
oh yeah I mean if you I'm honestly if
you I'll say something I'm probably
noise some people but obviously if you
look back in history numerous hot takes
are some of the worst yes I was about to
say that give you a ton of examples
everybody on the panel now seems to at
least like Metroid Prime or says it's a
good game yeah in 1908 in 2001 when the
game came out and there were a lot of
rumors online yeah I've been online for
a long time I was I was looking up codes
on game winners back you know Talk That
Talk here comes the studio called retro
studios Metroid which was a 2d
side-scrolling always destroyed veiny
essentially I back then you know and
it's gonna be first-person everyone
hated it everyone hated it it comes out
everyone loves it and now it's you know
it's a franchise the people who can't
wait for you come up to god of war
people were freaking out because there's
no jump button mmm-hmm the probably the
game of the generation according to a
lot of people absolutely but look about
Resident Evil 4 people did this we have
to give Nintendo credit you know they
they tend to blow that far oh my god
things that you would scratch your head
and say okay why would they do it and
just kind of reimagine some they're more
ballsy in that as far as the creativity
aspect you know whereas the others tend
to kind of stay a little bit more in
their lane so it'll be interesting to
see but now let's get to the hottest
part of this more thing but we here for
you know the whole topic we're the real
reason we're here for dick so here we go
the mic drop segment now wanna bring
this to the Lord round table we're gonna
do a bend the knee on this we're gonna
do a bend the knee on this one losing
pretty much I want to get everyone's
take what does the switch need to do to
drop that mic at e3
it means like what what is this signal
it has to be a singular thing it could
be a bunch of things you know what comes
your head that they need to do if they
do these same things it's over and I
need coffee news reveal Pokemon and
smash and a lot of people's gonna be
happy that that like that alone yes
those are big sellers you can keep
talking about new games but y'all buying
every single form you you new high up an
Xbox house for this long you go three to
an eight
just those two alone I think be enough I
think we're gonna I think we're gonna
see Metro Prime at least a trailer or
something
I'm gonna give it to the rest of the
lords first and again so let's go saw I
need that chapter Mike man you better
not say Pokemon no come on ya know I
think you dropped the mic moment I mean
for me I don't know if it's a dragon
like I think we get a 2d Mario Brothers
game and it's gold Super Mario Brothers
for I mean I had the Wii U at launch and
it was a great game well I think people
do not happy they're not happy with the
art style with the new Mario Brothers
series so I think like to appease that
it's been so long imagine adding a 2d to
player or whatever regular Mario a
classic Mario game he said Super Mario
Brothers for that would be to me I think
the nostalgia just would run rampant and
that would be like yeah I think it would
it would sell even Odyssey I don't know
if it's a $60 game but what actually
would entertain you wow this is this is
the real thing I'm a Microsoft fan
because we have real Internet
you shoot a gun you guys have to agree
that when it comes to the three big
platforms for some reason it's never
demanded for new games on it I'm sorry
it's just new I want them to do anything
okay I know they can always walk up
there they could be like part 4 retro
and it's so-so logo and you guys
they told you is behind a paywall all
right so you want this game right you
want the smash brothers but you gotta
pay the $20 to get in does it come with
game chat sir do you have the app listen
what I want is new experiences a mic
drop moment for me would be new
franchises they're showing and I know
that I'm gonna get some fun out of my
system my system sits there to be honest
with you okay so even some yeah pack
packs and I wanted those immeubles for
shovel knight I'm gonna support when
it's something different when it's
something I can't get from my boys not
have chances for thing is this um
well y'all looking for nostalgia I'm not
looking for that all right I'm looking
for them to push this next game to the
next generation and to see how we're
gonna use this switch in his unique ways
it's very unique I know we got a lab oh
and I know people was hating on it I
know I had a lot of jokes about it but
that's what I'm talking about I'm
talking about pushing the industry into
a different direction so my mic dry
moment will be
something as much as the industry into
another space Lord addict since you've
been unimpressed with Nintendo for this
sake what do they do
watch out oh yeah I'm exactly the
opposite of Lord King he don't want
nostalgia feeding in his I want to be on
that nostalgia kool-aid okay laughter
that's a lot a PNG by choice we were
discussing the showing something someone
but not necessarily the game itself like
look I have a ps4 Xbox one and a PC
capable of playing [ __ ] okay I could
play anything I want what why I bought a
switch for their games I don't like
games like splatoon I don't care about
like I just don't like the majority of
the games they make don't interest me so
what would it interest you what what oh
come on that's not that Pokemon go
[ __ ] language they give you that
Mario Party whatever number they are
okay and they give me that Super Smash
Brothers it actually put new characters
in it which I'm sure they will you know
how they do that I'm cool so then so the
nostalgia thing is really not a issue
like you actually like it you so I'm
confused because one minute you say you
don't like when they so you're okay when
as I get the vibe that whenever they do
a Wii U remaster and it sells well and
me a soft talk about it
that you like really are anti against
that because I played than we use right
but those are rematch against win it so
we're now and I hate you say hey you
want these nostalgic experiences I'm
talking about I'm not talking about
ports I'm talking about nine around
same as I'll turn around and iPod
backward-compatible I also want to see
where I'm hyping up switches online to
show me that you would be cool you want
that smash you want the let me clarify
when they keep an ounce and stuff that I
played on the Wii U or I have no
interest in I don't have no interest for
it
oh they give me a brand new Super Smash
Brothers I'm cool with that they give me
a new Mario Kart I'm hot you okay Mario
Kart because that was a great game on
the Wii U but that's like the only gay I
bought that came for the we were all
right cool let's get the guest did look
good the level what's that might drop
man what do they need to do for you so
I'm not I'm gonna try not to piggyback
on other people here but so I'm gonna go
with I'm just gonna title it third
parties you did with it could run on the
switch mmm so I'm talking like oh
because they didn't announce you know
call a dude already said they're not
bringing blop for for yes whatever small
wave Leslie so get up sorry no I mean
like it's it's we've been surprised by
what this what they can get on the
switch before but this has been really
good about that
you know just showing us a you guys like
it's still early in the consul's
lifestyle so we know that games tend
get better and they look better and
things run better as it goes on and I'm
actually really I'm still surprised
every time they done something like that
the second they said Wolfenstein I was
like no way proponents and I was like no
way but people are you know people
playing it they're like hey it runs it's
good it's good so listen I had all these
opportunities to play it before and I
waited to play it on the switch place
yourself oh did you know that game my
[ __ ] on the switch no it's probably not
the switch to buy a hoof inside
yes anger man who's a-comin oh yeah anti
Wolfenstein gamer and there are people
who are leading with crash bandicoot is
there people who waited to get it on
that system and the fact that we're
going to experience it all because it
doesn't make it a bad game that it
didn't sell well I think it's gonna be
it's time to so well on the switch
that's cool what do you need man mic
drop
I mean I don't really need too much cuz
I mean all these rumors is just too too
much I expect I might drop to be Pokemon
I expect them to announce that neither
mic drop what I would like to see is
these rumors about fortnight I want to
see if that's a possible mine you stop I
wanna see a fortnight that's a
possibility these rumors of fallout I
want to see that the possibility and
that's really it also this this whole
punch-out rumor like yeah that's what
I'm also looking forward to but I think
the whole my crops gonna be Pokemon I
mean we help me y'all know how they do
the directs they they start out with
whatever and then they have some big
surprise at the end of the wreck so
that's gonna be the my trap moment but
I'm wanting to see if this fortnight
rumor is a possibility and the fallout
that's what I'm looking forward to you
hold out
Lord spawn wave lets you anchor this
thing what
me that might drop moment uh I think if
they're gonna I guess do a mic drop
moment like that they need to pretty
much rely on themselves again third
party is so hit or miss with Nintendo
you know even if you get it it's not
gonna be like what you get on the Xbox
and the ps4 in terms of you know visuals
and everything so if I had if I had does
something intended would do they would
have to take 2018 and just cover it in
first party titles and we already know
about a lot of them because they said
III is gonna be a presentation for all
2018 games pretty much and then they
would follow up with the direct later so
if I had if I had to paint my calendar
from July to December I would say they
probably bring over a Mario maker in
July because because their games yeah
like that it was popular on Twitch and
definitely buying that that looked fun
yeah everybody that bring it over or you
can just do Mario maker to I don't
really know how you make a sequel to
that game though because you're just
building Mario levels Yoshi and August
Smash Bros September fire emblems over
Pokemon November and then you finish up
the year in December with actually
franchise this you know you're not
excited
you and added there are games that I
know that I'm either lukewarm or not
that concern about but I still
understand and respect the impact of the
title the difference between you guys
when you guys don't like something you
don't care and act like the rest of the
world don't like that what animal
Crossing's going to do hey I got a
purpose a good answer to that scenario
that you said I don't care exactly X
world yeah in your bubble buying all
these other people's copy I don't know
whole thing pretty much with everybody I
mean actually which girl stole my
fortnight that's the one that I
particularly you know I really want to
see that bonus which I think that'll be
cool obviously the Metroid that kind of
thing so everybody's kind of knocked it
out the park with the predictions any
thinks I want to do this last segment
have a little fun with it and um what an
ounce myths do you hope are not made run
eat it what don't you what Nintendo to
come on stage or or the director
man I don't want them to tell us more
about this online app I want that's the
first thing like don't talk about this
online ad oh look at this you can take
your splatoon's that you can no don't
show it I don't want to see it I don't
want to hear about it don't want nothing
with that come on man this online app
don't talk about it don't show it to me
nothing any like that in the switch
that's what I don't want to do
[Laughter]
[Music]
personally I just want them to stop with
the B team the the B team character is
the franchises I Yoshi come on
Yoshi thrown the B spot out there you
know he likes to roll you gotta keep you
know keep LeBron out you know they're
slowing down a little bit but I know I
know it's not completely true but it
seems like they're giving off the air
that they're they're not putting they're
you know they're a game out there right
now because we're trying to buy time or
something but you yeah and it starts to
feel like because like when things like
Kirby come out where it doesn't have a
universal appeal that kind of thing
people start saying there's a switch
drought well you know there's not hmm
but it starts to feel and I beat it
trust me I know that
what does it do need to do for you this
disease um
and not send me amiibos for me president
come on say talk about me both me I'm
like like y'all think I'm super like
some Super Nintendo fan via a she hate
amiibo was I I wish it would be plus
eight because they talking about the me
boat is and you would add not not fat
now piss me off and probably announced
like some like Star Fox zero or some
crap like that like I'll put it up and I
mean I know now pretty much like cheese
me Lord wave up very curious about this
look with piss you off I guess anything
with heavy motion controls I'm not
really I guess if they keep putting this
spotlight on like the 3d acid its I
understand why when they showed like
Luigi's Mansion on the 3ds like I know
why they didn't put the the X mega
whatever it was called the new Pokemon
rehabs Pokemon of whatever the last
Pokemon was it's not that direct what
was it kognito
like oh yeah ultra sun ultramoon like
hinted that that was coming out for the
switch to and then afterwards they
didn't clear know what's coming up for
just 3ds i know why they didn't do that
because i feel like they want the first
installment of that pokemon to be you
know have a lot more impact but I'm like
do I don't care like I want that I don't
want to wait here and a half for this I
want that how mad would you be if they
announced that the Pokemon game was
actually ultra Sun and mood on a switch
they can't do that how would you laugh
if it was Pokemon but I'll be
disappointed because I would I want the
standard Louis Malle wave basically you
want them to stay away from the PDS
focus even though it's successful for
them funny I think they can still throw
some stuff on there but that should kind
of start to I think back off and like a
third party system where third parties
can put their games over easily like
like Atlas yeah and get something that
base but I know why they're 70 something
million 3des is out there and they're I
think they're waiting for the switch to
get to at least 30 million before they
really start to back off to Mary and
that that's gonna probably happen this
year pretty easily so that's why later
at the end of this year they'll probably
back off and Pokemon is like the big
thing that's pulling people over anyway
so tonight it's nice a nice that we get
the numbers you know some of the
companies Microsoft makes my job a
little thank God it was got no trouble
there with EA throwing weird numbers
around there's a while what we discussed
I would say Mario Party
I'm crapping all over your childhood
years my fault when I was a child I'm
very honestly don't want them to be
announcing third parties that came out a
year or two ago
I don't you put in the ground and turns
into a bow is a pretty good meme and
online have you guys looked into like
how the engineers design that stuff on
it fascinating like some of the actually
did was is pretty cool
it's incredible
what they did with cardboard I just
don't want to hear damn more word about
it my gamers don't want to listen to it
or anything but I just like looking at
it because they're bringing into like
schools and stuff now yeah I've been
looking at like how the IR blaster on
the back of the the joy Khan actually
functions with the reflective tape and
the pulley systems and stuff they have
in there is I don't know who you gotta
put a patreon for that man to make to
make a lab oh right now y'all better put
up that patron with all of us doing that
one challenge many of those videos and
you have the hardest of the hard core
like yes pretty hot it's pretty hot five
minutes while we finish up your boy
river level then I'll do some of the
people I talked to that were that were
working on and PR and everything they
would show me some of the stuff they
were doing to get it working and it's
it's pretty impressive like I I think
some of the engineers behind it probably
deserve a little bit of cred
but I get why some people don't like the
lab I understand completely obviously
but for kids it is very very interesting
to them like my nephew thinks it's like
magic and I have to explain it to him
then I explained oh the IR sees the
reflective tape and that's how it knows
you know this piano is being pressed and
it does at least get them learning which
is which is which is good I think yeah
man for me and I think I'm doubling down
I forgot who said it but I think if they
jump on stage and they double down on
that yeah one of my predictions was I'm
hoping shout to drink as guys shout out
the kids movie you know I'm really
hoping on this discord partnership with
Microsoft and hopefully something with
Nintendo to at least allow that app on
there and that functionality because we
all know like normal if you one of the
first to have you remember when a switch
came out and Lord King would laugh at me
but I would watch your video and I'm
like yo the functionality for a headset
mic is in the switch this is real quick
we was out there purchasing all that
stuff pre purchase and you know
everybody put a switch he said
I'm purchasing the best when they got
thing about it if you play slow tune and
land it works records he's getting a
check from Nintendo right
negative really funny that you're saying
that if you go back and look at what my
videos when the app came out I myself
and Max Dreamcast guy spent about 15
minutes laughing at it on like using it
there and I got a Nintendo be like
yelled at because you're playing
splatoon and I didn't put in ask Weimer
that they sent it to me but I I saw the
email like are they yelling at me about
laughing at because we were like ripping
this laughing at their app I don't know
that's why I brought this but they're
using this really weird app that would
be the most disappointed it's bad found
that it works in tune because now people
are looking at and they're like why are
we using how we're using it and shut up
the Kofi's tweet man like I saw your
tweet I had the same feeling which is
like we waited a whole year for you to
announce this like this no voice chat
not even not even messaging you know I
mean right now the friends list is just
like our virtual online store Callisto
he played this for hours ago straining
because the old platforms had it there
in the new genitive not this system out
of the park but they refused and it just
doubling they just got the game
it is going on oh we have a lot of fun I
like this what happened with Microsoft
they would have sold that Xbox brand
years ago they just think they have the
balance though in the that's true the
three communicate together because it's
like one is the best surfaces some of
the best versions Mikey the server's
send data to my console so much faster
when it comes to downloading like the
e-stop is so slow the trash that too
much Microsoft's like oh you got gigabit
speed here's a gigabit boom and just
throws it at me and there they're online
integration is amazing game pass is the
best value in in games which I just said
Nintendo got the games sony has some
type of pedigree when it comes to
bringing a cinematic feel to some of the
games and stuff and they have their
graphics and really nice stuff and
Microsoft has the Internet and the
connectivity with your friends if we can
merge that all into one system and we
would pay we'd be paying a lot of money
per game then because they love to say
I'll ask only one question before we get
out of I was gonna ask you because I
know I don't want to go too long with
this last thing but um we all know what
has happened in King laughed and kicked
when I found when I told him the news
obviously about the switch being hacked
right so yeah the whole thing is now we
know that it sits on the Tegra level
there's nothing that they can do from a
firmware standpoint to prevent it so we
know new revisions are coming so my
question was one way was just that in
reference to a new revision do you think
that this now speeds up the process of
almost maybe like a switch 2.0 so that
maybe we get a little bit of like the
latest Tegra latest products that
accelerate that you think what the hack
situation if anything it's
probably slows it down really well they
have they have so many lanes in their
manufacturing warehouses now they're
pumping out these chips so technically
we're making a separate ship that we at
least know about because people pulled
apart the the firmware so they're gonna
be basically putting those on pallets
and getting those ready while they're
probably playing around in designing
other stuff in the background with
nvidia and video makes a lot of money
from the switch so they're gonna be
putting something new in it again and
again and again apparently it's a
20-year partnership of course yeah right
now so they'll continue to do that they
they love their their Tegra stuff now
because it also powers they're on their
self-driving car system and everything
and that makes a lot of money because
Tesla like loves them so absolutely
they're 2020 that's my prediction will
see in 2020 that's actually that would
be the longest we've ever gone without
with the revision taking that long
yeah now I was just curious because
again this is me jumping back into the
Nintendo ecosystem since god knows how
long so I guess I was curious as far as
like the revision cycles do they tend to
I go to 3d s you guys that had 3d s is
like was it at every two year thing was
it like how long did you wait between I
think yeah I think for example like the
Gameboy advanced the SP I think that
might have been a year I don't think
they're gonna do it I think they're
gonna they're gonna ride this out 2020
we're gonna get a revision so even with
the hack you think is just gonna
internally replace the jet but we'll
keep the same form factor we'll keep
everything well notice it like you don't
people don't notice it but like all
these systems change multiple times the
ps4 has changed I want to say seven
times now the ps3 changed some Ahmet
like 12 times or something dangerous
[ __ ] the Xbox one controller changed
like a hundred times I goddamn hearts as
parts get cheaper they keep putting them
together and making the system you know
she knows they can as parts are
available and I just they all do it
obviously but you're gonna see yo you'll
see it silently like the model number on
the back will probably be one digit will
be different or so be definite so it'll
be as like a subtle chain yeah
so the room was complete addict is happy
the ìiî to tender protection Mendes fans
all of you individually a man follow you
guys for a long time and I've seen my
journey with the switch and I figured I
had to get you guys on you guys
entertain me you guys are very
knowledgeable great channels let's do
these outros start with lost bone wave
but absolute pleasure for coming through
and I'm a huge fan like this bears like
to see an end of gaming right bad so
where can define people find you what
else you got you find me on a spawn wave
I'm actually I was actually working on a
video right before this I'll be
continuing it I'm actually gonna build a
nice little Raspberry Pi plastic system
you can put all your games on it from
China's like a joke me and Sean did for
our GT together just for fun just cuz it
made a good topic for a video you know
get some you already have lab you get
knockoff cardboard to build these things
it was it was funny now I wanted to
build something that be a little more
interesting for people who cannot get
the classic systems easily like remember
the NES classic was yes impossible why
don't you build one that plays
everything so we'll do that and I found
a really cool little Super Nintendo case
that nice and that spawn cast is still
every Saturday 9:00 p.m. get your plug
or man yeah man every Saturday at 9 p.m.
Eastern Time have a lot of fun on there
talk about games and stuff in the past
week it's a good time thank you very
much for coming to so Lloyd coffee with
the smoke I just like taking jokes I
like it's not serious to me another day
people who know me know I enjoy all
games on all platforms I just why I just
want to play great games and it was a
pleasure talking to y'all today
shoutout to the whole panel shoutout to
the guests
hopefully uh me and King David can go
one on one press
I'm very pinyin at a point if you guys
don't know if y'all want to try and try
me you know anyways yeah yeah y'all can
check out my channel press our coffee or
just coffee now I'm also check out my
podcast press our podcast and yeah it's
been a pleasure being on and hopefully
I'll be on again one day is always there
if you don't plug that up I stop podcast
that's why every workday at what time
press our podcast is every Thursday at
8:30 p.m.
please check out his developer about his
interview with development band and I
call Demetri from cold it was
fantastical DJ man I gotta get jamming
on the show America as well and Alex and
stuff yeah definitely gotta love I love
the panel Greg the bunch of people
they're doing good content out there man
respect it do it man out here bus it is
good early that starfox race where could
have 5 people 5 so you guys can find
this all at up potentially perfect here
on YouTube over for us on on Twitter and
Instagram so what we do over on our
YouTube channel if you're into it is we
like to talk about things that generally
don't get talked about such as like
video games as art that's not really
topic that people talk about anymore a
girlfriend mode did a video on that so
it's a it's not always play for them on
things but I think it's it's things that
need to discuss and I do scripted videos
essays on that just to go ahead I know I
know spawn already like you know so
equities about but like I'm telling you
I watched his stuff so much absolutely I
started walking before I got patron I
think it like since 10,000 fibers are
basically hitmen that's where you get
your news and so definitely really
really check him out on Saturday he does
his own podcast too so but yeah that's
what we do we do funny stuff because we
believe that video games are fun they
should stay fun and that's what they are
we gonna get some more tracks male like
you with that guitar man unless boys
nice it's like Prince young pretty big
dough too young you know what all the
way oh thank you for coming through sir
and again as well love the video you did
was all in reference to when the
Nintendo online announcement was going
on where can I find people find you and
also what do you have cooking up alright
so you can find me
YouTube Nintendo Direct Twitter you can
direct the I indirect is one because
that was already taken so through a man
thanks for having me man I really do
appreciate it I it's been a long time
I've been wanting to come on here but it
long I've been waiting so it was nice
meeting spawn way that was awesome like
I said I I do follow you I like
everybody's thing I know really yeah but
he knows his stuff and he's a nice dude
man for real
is it sad that like where I don't like
mess with Nintendo at all cookies like I
really want to get smaller I was like
one of my more popular videos is
actually a PlayStation 4 video a lot of
people greatness awaits me because I
opened up that do controller yes I saw
you take it out of it that was nice yeah
now like right now like like you said
you talked about mine indie spotlight
that's coming tomorrow and then after
this I will be streaming old-school
Sunday as I do
they school games so that's what I got
cooking up so once again thanks for
having me
spawn wave nice meeting you everybody
else Kofi it was it was no it was a good
time
absolutely and the Lords in the realm as
usual Lord adequate smoke all day hating
this you know what you got go to a lot
at accredit a big cooking besides
getting motion sickness on stage of
decay I'm probably gonna place I'm gonna
try and play that that punch came this
on the switch yeah I'm gonna try
keyboard games playing on the
PlayStation as well be getting anymore
our Matic impressions any addict reviews
coming up on the channel in the gaming
addict channel no but I like that this
which brings that energy out Lord saw
better feel good to have backup like
destroy the nerve of you solve
[Laughter]
thank you for the patriotic Belgian man
you worked tremendously hard on that
salute Louis aw man
put those dick and then dismiss the
patriarch Ilia preciate any any sort of
help but you know thank you for just
being here every single week yeah man we
just got trying to go bigger and better
absolutely
Lord King with this everybody was
fantastic today and I really didn't know
what I was getting myself into until I
saw your line this was right in this
part off because individually everyone
brought a fantastic energy and I'm heavy
on energy
Kofi I love your energy I swear I will
get on your podcast I will get out there
with you and we can chop it up over
there I told you I like energy before so
it was no problem I told you hit me
anything I will go out there we will
figure it out because our time
difference is weird but we'll figure it
out um small ways I've been messing with
you on the load checking out your videos
and when you said the raspberry I didn't
know that you was so quick on the draw
rebuttals as far as you already heard
whatever they say
[Laughter]
man potentially really be talking Manalo
you know edmo your job man and we
actually recorded a shoulder didn't
record he got me so hype for that for
the show of it oh I'm gonna get down
with him on that we're gonna do that
show cuz he gave me some a wealth of
knowledge that's what I talked about
wealth of knowledge please guys make
sure your DME you get to know each other
um Nintendo this is the first time I'm
meeting you and I love your energy broke
they jumped in the room and it wasn't
like you came in all quiet and me we got
sovereign finished on the patreon
hopefully he can help me finish the
website so we get those links out to you
guys for the three orders for the
t-shirts we really would like the
pre-orders to go so I know exactly how
many I'm shipping out we're trying to do
a bundle type of thing so if you buy
four shirts you get one shirt for free
or if you buy the whole package you get
the pink shirt your wife really chic a
swag out with you two on the podcast you
know when she upstairs all probably
she's like join in the podcast rocking a
shirt that'd be a good thing um closer
to e3 we're gonna start doing little
things called the road to e3 also got
combat talk coming it'll be a separate
thing I can go in-depth on you know
boxes and fighting and how to act like a
fighter and be a fighter and how to have
integrity so um I just had a great
podcast this was all the panel all the
gas band was fantastic great to talk
game and have some fun
have some smoke make sure you guys hit
the Lights approach again shouts off
upon that uh patreon again you're trying
to make this podcast bigger and better
slowly growing and
this is just an extension of the
Saturdays that the law is used to have
together just gaming so um yeah
everybody enjoy your Sunday and have
some fun and next week we'll have this
sony will bring it up to bat glass so
special surprise